[Music]
computer chips probably make you think
of this
since it was founded in 1968 Intel has
dominated the chip Market this symbol
outside means you have the standard
inside it was the world's largest chip
maker by revenue for 25 years and it's
still America's largest chip Company by
sales in town but then came AMD in 2022
the longtime rival took Intel's top spot
in market value reaching a market cap of
over 200 billion dollars it was the
first time that ever happened in part
this recent achievement can be traced
back to one risky and expensive decision
AMD made that changed the game not just
for the company but for computing so how
did AMD finally catch up to Intel
July 1968 Silicon Valley a small group
of Engineers founded Intel a startup
dedicated to chips which are essentially
the brains of a computer Intel
prioritized development from the start
and didn't report any sales in the first
six months meanwhile 20 minutes down the
road and 10 months later a former
co-worker of those Engineers founded AMD
or Advanced Micro Devices AMD was making
chips that Intel had already made
focusing more on keeping up than getting
ahead then in 1970 Intel came out with
this the first semiconductor memory chip
a year later it was the best-selling
semiconductor device in the world amd's
Hardware didn't sell the same way AMD
really came up as kind of a an Intel
copycat company that was making
alternatives to Intel just like maybe a
little bit cheaper and things like that
so they were they kind of came in second
in a lot of ways to Intel especially
when it came to CPUs and the rise of
CPUs CPUs are central processing units
basically chips that solve problems
here's how they work first the base a
flat piece of silicon silicon is a
semiconductor which means it's
conductive but can be made more
conductive by adding other materials
like phosphorus or Boron on that silicon
piece there is a pathway of transistors
which turn currents on and off these
strings of electronic blips read as one
or zero and come together as binary
information that information goes
through this a core in simplified terms
the core takes in a problem and shoots
out an answer those answers help
determine how to respond to requests
like opening a web page or sending an
email if the chip is the main brain the
core is like a tiny second brain
by 1971 Intel released the first
programmable microprocessor another
success the company churned out new chip
after a new chip creating industry
standard after industry standard back in
those times it was able to put together
this combination of marketing itself
well and creating some of the world's
best technology to become the PowerHouse
that it became back then
by 1997 Intel chips served as the brains
of 84 of the world's computers it had 10
times AMD sales and six times its
manufacturing capacity now anyone can
have all the brain power they want just
look for a PC with an Intel processor
inside going into the New Millennium
amd's market value lagged behind intels
fast forward to late 2014 when the
company tasked new CEO Lisa Sue with
turning things around before Sue's
tenure the company had fought off rumors
it would be sold and laid off workers
so behind the scenes Sue began working
on a new innovation I hope you guys have
your money ready we've made plenty of
processors AMD released a new design for
their high performance chips that beat
many of Intel's benchmarks first the
transistors were organized in a new way
on the chips called Zen architecture at
the same time AMD rethought how chips
themselves were made Intel had been
focusing on making a single CPU answer
questions really really fast AMD decided
that for some of its chips it moved to
chiplets instead of having one big
silicon chip there were multiple small
chips in the same package connected
together and acting like one CPU that
strategy conferred some key advantages
in terms of power consumption in terms
of cost but still performed very well
against Intel's products this chip
redesign was the pivotal factor that
gave AMD an edge and that really helped
AMD return to more of a leadership
position in the market when these
products launched in 2017. experts said
that comparable AMD CPUs were less
expensive and faster than Intel's our
competition is priced at a thousand
dollars
MD ryzen 4.99 by mid-2018 its market cap
had shot up to over 30 billion dollars
almost exactly five years after the
release of Verizon in 2022 AMD passed
Intel and market cap for the first time
but it didn't hold that spot for long
still it reflects the investor sentiment
about the future of the two companies
clearly investors see a lot of positive
things in the future for AMD given its
share gains against Intel then the sales
of PCS which Drive CPU usage slumped
shipments in the second quarter of 2022
dropped in the steepest decline in nine
years in July Intel posted its biggest
Revenue drop in more than a decade a
month later AMD surpassed Intel again in
market value Intel's trying to
aggressively correct its technology path
and become you know the Undisputed
leader again in in chip manufacturing
while AMD was also hit by market forces
its Revenue Inc increased by fourteen
percent AMD is a little bit more
flexible in a sense than Intel because
it's smaller and AMD does not have any
manufacturing facilities like Intel does
that kind of gives AMD some flexibility
to adapt to this this environment
perhaps without the kinds of uh cuts
that Intel is making but AMD May face
even more challenges after the US
government imposed export restrictions
on some chips in manufacturing equipment
CEO Lisa Sue said it is minimal impact
on our Revenue in the near term Intel is
building new factories called Fabs to
help keep as much of production as
possible in the US where the oil
reserves are Define geopolitics for the
last five decades where the Fabs are for
the next five decades is more important
whether AMD will continue to hold its
own against Intel will depend on how
well its Innovations have laid the
groundwork for the way forward
[Music]
foreign